reason is the certainty of being all
reality this in itself or this reality
is however a universal pure and simple
the pure abstraction of reality it is
the first positivity in which
self-consciousness is in its own self
explicitly for itself and I is therefore
only the purest sensuality of the
existent or is the simple category the
category which formerly had the meaning
of being the essentiality of the
existent and it was undetermined whether
the existence as such or the existent
contrasted with consciousness is now the
essentiality or the simple unity of the
existent only as a reality that thinks
in other words the category means this
that self-consciousness and being are
the same essence the same not through
comparison but in and for themselves it
is only the one sided spurious idealism
that lets this unity again come on the
scene as consciousness on one side
confronted by and in itself on the other
but now this category or simple unity of
self-consciousness and being possesses
difference in itself for its essence is
just this to be immediately won and self
same in other nests or in absolute
difference the difference therefore is
but is perfectly transparent and a
difference that is at the same time none
it appears as a plurality of categories
since idealism proclaims the simple
unity of self consciousness to be all
reality and immediately makes it the
essence without having grasped it as the
absolutely negative essence only this is
had negation determinate Nisour
difference within it this second
assertion is even more incomprehensible
than the first that is that in the
category there are differences or
species of categories the assertion is
such as also the assertion as to any
specific number of species of categories
is a new assertion which however itself
implies that we no longer have to accept
it as an assertion for since the
difference originates in the pure I and
the pure understanding itself it is
thereby made explicit that the immediacy
the making of assertions and mere
finding of differences is here given and
we begin to comprehend but to pick up
the plurality of categories again in
some way or other as a welcome fine
taking them for example from the various
judgments and complacently accepting
them so is in fact to be regarded as an
outrage on science where else should the
understanding be able to demonstrate a
necessity if it is unable to do so in
its own self which is pure necessity
in paragraph 235 and also in the
paragraph to follow we're going to see
Hegel referring a lot to the categories
and since hingle is in this broad stream
of German idealism it's you know sort of
a automatic response to think that he's
talking about the conscient categories
and then building off of a conscience
basis and I think it's very important to
realize as we move into this that first
of all category as a technical term as
as a concept in philosophy the antedates
cut it goes all the way back to
Aristotle who has a book called the
categories now what Hegel is doing in
terms of his use of categories is
neither along the same lines as Kant nor
along the same lines as Aristotle but is
working from within a tradition in which
people would be convergent with both of
those and he's adding his own sort of
additional views into it he wants
something of categories not only as you
might say clasificado a principals or
whatever else do you want to conceive
the month it's rather difficult to say
exactly what they would be other than
just calling them categories he wants to
see them as something more dynamic is
coming out of consciousness they do play
a very important structuring role so
that it is similar to what's going on in
both Aristotle and in time for conduct
play an absolutely irreplaceable
structuring role not only for our
experience of things but for our ability
to speak about them to judge about them
and to think about them even more
importantly for time to know them now
all that said what I want to do is very
quickly look at the very start of the
paragraph and then jump to the end and
then go to all this this developmental
stuff that's happening that I've got
charted here on the board so equal
starts out by saying reason is the
certainty of being all reality we've
already you know covered that quite a
bit
this in itself or this reality is
however a you virtual pure and simple
that sounds pretty good so far but then
notice what he says after that the pure
abstraction of reality so it's not
reality itself we haven't finished with
this this Universal is not what we would
call a concrete Universal it's it's an
abstract Universal so he comes I mean
says it's the first positivity in which
self-consciousness is in its own self
explicitly for itself and I is therefore
only the purest sense reality of the
existent or as a simple category that's
what we've got over here and we're going
to march our way through this so the eye
as pure essentiality or simple category
what what is he talking about there well
we've seen this I in quotes always come
up a number of times that it you know
the if you want to translate that as ego
you can I just don't read Freudian
overtones into that right it's the pure
sensuality it's the pure vision right
[ __ ] something we've talked about this
before think about that which asserts
itself that which thinks center around
that which is important right whereas
the simple category now what does he
mean by category in this case that by
which we are understanding other things
and classifying them with what's
providing you might say structure or or
sense to them now let's let's get very
far ahead towards the end of the
paragraph this is the this fun enough
question how many categories are there
why are there this this amount of
categories or these particular
categories and not others so he was
dissatisfied with thoughts approach to
this he says the assertion and such is
also the assertion has to any specific
number of species of categories is a new
assertion which itself implies that we
no longer have to accept it as an
assertion what Kant was do it was
the same thing that many other
philosophers do you know in trucks terms
he calls this transcendental he's
realized here easy not realizing he's
he's proposing to us what must in fact
be the case for the things that we say
yes this is the case to be the case let
me say that one more times I've put a
lot of cases into that so kind of saying
that we have to have the categories that
we do in part cuz they are there right
he's saying these are there whether we
philosophers grasped them as such that
we didn't in the past where we
imperfectly did so but these are there
and they play an important structuring
role in making sense out of whatever it
is that we experience we think about we
imagine so on and so forth
we realize that by saying well what has
to be the case for what we've got here
to be as we think that it is we're
starting with it with saying well this
is the case then we're sort of
extrapolating well what has to be the
case in order for this to happen
Hegel thinks that when cut does that
there's some slippage there it doesn't
really need to be the way that cut has
presented it so it kind of makes these
these you know very sweeping assertions
groundbreaking you know we talk about
the Copernican you know turn in
epistemology and metaphysics you know
the move away from saying you know let's
look at the objects of knowledge so
let's look at the subject the one who's
knowing which you know kind of course
isn't the first person to do that
Aristotle did as well but so the Thomas
Aquinas sort of other people but the
conscious doing it in a very serious fun
demented way a radical way so he who
goes out and he says it's a new
assertion which implies we no longer
have to accept that is an assertion if
in history there can be a particular
time where a monocot comes around
says aha here are the categories you
know these have been active the entire
time we just didn't really know it that
should raise some legal things alarming
bowels or ready flags we should hope why
didn't we know it all this time
especially since we didn't know pretty
smart people working on the problem
Aristotle started talking about
categories you know two millennia ago so
Hegel says we need to consider whether
this assertion really ought to be
accepted and he says since the
difference originates in the pure I and
the pure understanding itself it's made
explicit that the immediacy the making
of assertions and mere finding of
differences is here given and we begin
to comprehend but here's criticizing
come to pick up the plurality of
categories again in some way or another
as a welcome find taking them for
example from the various judgments and
complacently accepting them so is to be
regarded as an outrage on science that
is not naming context pleasantly but who
is it that you know said well we've got
these kinds of judgments and that tells
us what kind of what nothing what kind
what number of categories we have well
it was cut Hegel saying that's a little
arbitrary and why do we have to accept
it like that if we do that's that's
certainly being unscientific or if you
don't like the word scientific less
rigorous than we ought to be so he says
we're all should the understanding be
able to demonstrate a necessity if it's
unable to do this do so in its own self
which it is pure necessity so you forget
these category structure of the
understanding and the understanding is
that which we're using to make sense of
everything else unless we go beyond the
understanding right into it's a reason
for not there should be some necessity
that is demonstrable within the scope of
the understanding and Hegel saying that
just hasn't been the case let's look
down with this this other middle part
right so we started we got to the
beginning of this
category as being the essentiality the
basin height of what's being translated
here as the existent the scientists that
which has being that which that which is
real that which possesses some sort of
being whatever we want to make of this
so the essentiality of the existent the
category is that this is very different
than when we think of conscient
categories or when we think about the
Aristotelian categories right the the
ways in which we can we can predicate
things even if we confine it to the
category of substance it's you know
where the others are accidents in
Aristotle we don't have a sort of unity
like this but the eye that is involved
in reason at this stage brings that to
the table and things have been somehow
unified so it looks like there's only
one category at this point one single
category for all being and so there's an
ambiguity here is that above the
existence as such or is it contrasted
with consciousness this is going to lead
us to the the next stage he says the
category which formerly had the meaning
of being the essentiality of existence
right is now the essentiality we're
simply unity of the existent but in a
very important way that reveals to us
what what progress has been made
it's the existent as a reality that
thinks so what is centering the category
or you might say the operation of
category is a categorization right this
is this you know bringing of
essentiality or noticing of essentiality
it's the reality the things it is that
is us we are the reality that thinks we
can think of ourselves in terms of
consciousness or self-consciousness or
reason or spirit any of these things but
that's really that's really human being
so he goes on and he says here we go the
cat
means this that self-consciousness and
beating are the same essence and I put
an equal sign there so Bri VA ting a
little bit they are the same hasn't
self-consciousness is and being we are
not radically cut off from the rest of
being because it is as we've remark for
us so he goes on and he says the same
they're the same not through comparison
but in and for themselves it's only the
one-sided spurious idealism that lets
this unity again come on the scene is
consciousness on one side confronted by
it in itself on the other but now this
category are simply unity of
self-consciousness and being possesses
difference he says in itself anything
that really is for Hegel has already got
difference within itself working right
itself others we've we've gone through
this many times this leads us to another
stage where now we realize that because
there is the category this has to be
present to us as a plurality of
categories very interesting transition
there isn't it so he says the difference
here we go
it's essences to be just best to be
immediately one itself saying in other
Nisour an absolute difference this was
something that we saw in force in the
understanding right this this you know
being the same in other nests repelling
itself from itself repelling the self
same from it and welcoming the other
which is itself so he goes on when he
says since I appeared as a plurality of
categories and since idealism proclaims
the simple unity of self consciousness
to be all reality and immediately makes
it the essence about having grasped it
as the absolutely negative essence only
this has negation determinate Nisour
difference with it this
difference right so what we end up with
is this he says more incomprehensible
assertion which is still comprehensible
that there is a plurality of categories
and that there are in the category there
are differences
once our sheet up right separations or
species it's translated here or if you
want to call it types Artin of
categories so you know is he saying that
that's something like what Aristotle or
what cat was doing is is totally
off-base
no they weren't the be-all and end-all
listings of the categories in part
because they're still as Hegel feels a
kind of arbitrariness to it and there
isn't a day you know development of it
taking place it's very hard to account
for why do these only appear in
formulation very late in the game if you
think about hunt but there is a
plurality at work and the question that
we want to determine then is well you
know how many categories are there and
why are those categories the categories
that they are so what we're really
asking about is a kind of
intelligibility all right we are trying
to make sense out of the categories and
these all should still connect up with
some sort of unity as well in that
plurality so what he's done here is is
essentially greatest a problem for us he
hasn't provided us with the solution for
it he's not actually going to provide us
with a full solution in any way in this
this section that won't this sort of
thing is going to have to happen much
later on but he has framed the problem
now because in this way the pure
essential 'ti of things like their
difference belongs to reason we can
strictly speaking no longer talk of
things at all that is something which
would be for consciousness merely the
negative of itself for to say that the
many categories are species of the pure
category means that this latter is still
their genus or essence and is not
opposed to them but ambiguity already
attaches to them since in their
plurality they possess other nests in
contrast to the pure category in fact
they contradict the pure category by
such plurality and the pure unity must
supersede them in itself thereby
constituting itself a negative unity of
the differences but as a negative unity
it excludes from itself both the
differences as such as well as that
first immediate pure unity as such and
is a singular individual a new category
which is consciousness as exclusive that
is consciousness for which there is an
other the singular individual is the
transition of the category from its
notion to an external reality the pure
schema which is both consciousness and
sense it is a singular individual in an
exclusive unit the pointing to an other
but this other of the category is merely
the other first mentioned categories
that is pure essentiality and pure
difference and in this category that is
just in the positiveness of the other or
in this other itself consciousness is
equally itself each of these different
moments points or refers to another but
at the same time they do not attained
other nests the pure category points to
the species which pass over into the
negative category or singular individual
this latter however points back to them
it is itself pure consciousness which is
aware in each of them of being always
this clear unity with itself but a unity
which equally is referred to another
which in being has vanished and in
vanishing also comes into being again
paragraph 236 is particularly
challenging for two different reasons
that that are connected up together the
first is that he's going to talk about
the single or singular individual as
being a new type of categories so this
challenges our understanding of category
which you know is closely tied together
with this this action of classification
and contest rightly recognized as
aristotle also recognized with
predicating things of things with making
judgments so how does individuality fit
in with that here's the second part that
makes it particularly challenging hiegel
throws it out of the table but it
doesn't really work that out in this
section this is one of those paragraphs
where there's a lot of sort of charting
things out that refer to each other
things that we're supposed to like you
know keep in our head as consciousness
phenomenologically following along with
Hegel's
unfolding of the history of
consciousness and we're supposed to keep
all these things you know in our head
and figure well what's connected to what
and and there's no actual resolution
here in this paragraph but it is
important because he is he's setting out
though the problematic he's deepening it
so let's take a look at what he's what
he's actually saying he starts out by
saying because in this way the pure
sensuality of things like their
difference belongs to reason we can
strictly speaking no longer talk of
things at all that is something which
would be for consciousness merely the
negative of itself that is everything it
is for consciousness in this this area
of reason now we move past the previous
stages and so there's nothing that's
really fundamentally alien to to
consciousness
so things in a certain sense aren't
things the way that we traditionally
imagined them
that slide because in the next
paragraphs to come we're gonna see some
some important discussion about about
that particularly as we move into
observing reason now he says them for to
see the many categories our species of
the pure category that's what we've got
down here right and there's more than
three categories I just want to put more
Sanskrit on the board and each one of
them is an is an art species of category
right there are species of the pure
category the pure essentially the unity
which is in fact their genus and we're
being pretty familiar with this sort of
motive of classifying things now this
led to a big problem as people started
thinking about well how to classify the
totality of beings and being so one way
that you can make sense out of this it
is to say that you know we start at
these lower levels and we see how things
are connected with each other
we see that they're all part of a you
know particular species I'm a human
being
you're a human being we're not in the
same species as you know tree slog or
you know hermit crab or something like
that but we have things in common with
that I mean a living you know certain
kinds of systems we don't you get too
too technical with this but we have
geniuses right and then maybe there's
like different kinds of geniuses but
they should all somehow connect up with
some overarching genus shouldn't they
being perhaps you know being itself the
being of meeting and so you know that's
when we can talk about some sort of pure
category what we're doing here is is
essentially metaphysics and we're trying
to figure how things actually fit
together Hegel is going to turn things
on their head very quickly here so he
says that the many categories are
species of the pure category this means
that this ladder is still there genus
and or essence and is not opposed to
them
that's a problem that if it's not
opposed to them
so he says ambiguity already attaches to
them because in their plurality they
possess other nosov right this category
is this category by not being this
category this is something that we saw
already at the level of you know sense
perception with you know sense certainty
right but but not what we're looking at
is the other nasur of each of these you
might say category small C with the
category large C that is supposed to be
there their unity and again we saw this
problem with the nature of the universal
already in the earlier consciousness
sections so he says they possess
awareness in contrast to the pure camera
in fact they contradict the pure
category by such plurality so not only
are they opposed as individual species
they're also opposed as a whole by
deviating a whole bunch of different
things
and he says the pure unity must
supersede them in itself thereby
constituting itself a negative unity of
the differences now as a negative unity
if you says it excludes from itself the
differences as such as well as that
first immediate pure unity as such and
we get a new thing the singular
Universal singular individuals have the
singular Universal but the singular
individual it's kind of a funny limit to
say singular Universal because when we
talk about the individual like this we
are in a certain sense doing something
that is a universal this is where we get
to what's particularly challenging about
this how do we think individuality which
is where the whole game of doing things
plays itself out right I'm an individual
you're an individual how do we think
this out in terms of you know
essentiality or categories so he says
the singular
individual is a new category which is
consciousness as exclusive consciousness
for whom there is and other the singular
individually says is the transition of
the category from its notion to an
external reality there's an
externalization that's going on here
like for example the fact that I can see
myself you can't see me so we have a
very complex thing going on here because
the singular individual is you it is me
it's also you know us being other for
each other
isn't it but there's another know
they're going on here as well so he says
the other rivet is of the category is
merely the other first mention
categories pure essentiality and pure
difference I've got those here but that
is this right here and this right here
or perhaps what's with you between them
so what does that inference
he says in this category
just as in the positiveness of the other
or the other itself consciousness is
equally itself so this is all
consciousness right well other and
individual so now he says each of these
different moments points are refers to
one another each of these that we've
been talking about refers to the others
so this is one big dynamic system
none of them are identical to each other
and yet none of them are totally
separate from each other and you notice
I've got this arrow here so you know
this is the dynamic of this unity and
it's you know negativity plays that so
far we get the singular individual but
we can also go to it this way as well
right we can say well let me go from the
genus down to the species and what's
below a species well you know the
singular individual that fits in
to the species so no matter which way we
go we wind up with the singular
individual there so he says they don't
attain to others
pure category points of the species
passes over to the negative category of
singular individual this points back to
them why because it's putting back to
them as its other it is itself pure
consciousness which is aware of each of
them of being always this clear unity
with itself but a unity which equally is
referred to another which in being has
vanished and in vanishing also comes
into being again so we see you know once
again the typical thing work
this entire thing here is consciousness
we're doing a phenomenology we're saying
what is present to consciousness and
what is other has this kind of strange
existence insofar as we focus on it it
starts to vanish it starts to recede we
lose our grasp on it insofar as we move
away from it attains to prominence yet
once again so although this is what we
need to keep in mind moving forward